okay um
we'll be starting in just a moment
please be patient i need to
start the live stream as you can see
annal is here with us
if you give me
just a minute to get this started
very good
all right thank you all for being here
and
today's career master class how career
paths have changed
pursuing success through lifelong
learning if you hear that noise in the
background it's because i have a cat
um
anal sanchez corey is uh a neil center
for he is the director of learning and
development
for asian pacific or cgi
and
he'll be
giving the class today but
like to start off with is an instruction
oops on how to participate in the
webinar
if you're not familiar with webex
controls you please put your questions
for anil in the
um q a box
and
you can put chat messages in we will see
those
um but the questions should go in the q
a so we can keep track of those and
we'll ask those in the q a
period of the webinar toward the end
i'm going to be doing a couple of polls
and
the first one here is
a poll on
how much work experience you have so i
know can have an idea of the audience so
give me a moment to get that launched
and
if you are watching on youtube live or
linkedin live
um by all means
put your answers in the chat box for the
comments
and we'll just keep this open for about
thirty seconds
the second question is about how you're
feeling today we've been asking that
since the beginning of the pandemic
just to
keep track of how people are doing
and in 10 seconds we'll close the poll
okay
so we see that the
the biggest portion of the audience
about 40
are
people with 10 years of experience
so we have a fairly
experienced audience today and
the rest of the audience is pretty
evenly split among the different
experience levels
so anil that gives you an idea of who is
with us today
and
let me introduce you
as i mentioned uh anil is the director
of learning and development for asian
pacific for cgi
a
multinational um
it
services company that develops systems
for
corporations around the world
and he is a
recognized leader
in learning and development has
been named uh
personally as a
leader in
various awards
and
by various publications so we are very
lucky to have him here today and
welcome
and i'm going to go ahead and let you
take over the
oh you're on mute
i'm gonna let you
thank you
thanks thanks for the introduction and
uh a warm welcome good morning good
afternoon good evening depending on
wherever you are joining from across the
globe so
it's interesting so one of the questions
was how are you feeling today so i'm
going to start by saying thumbs up from
my side and it it's a very you know and
steve thanks a lot for doing this
especially asking that question because
this is my second webinar i'm doing with
you
um so it's very interesting to
collaborate but
for the sake of audience
uh steve and i did a dry run two hours
ago
which was
9 pm for him in san francisco
8 30 or so or nine for me in the morning
and now two hours later we're back here
so it's a very interesting connected
world we're working in where time zones
don't matter and
and you know
before he came into that session he had
a long day now i had a long day so it's
very interesting so it's it's important
to ask each other how are we doing
that's really
critical so i'm really excited uh with
uh
you know spending time with all of you
today especially it's a very
very evolving topic so i'll quickly
share my screen
and if i can get a confirmation that
you're able to see it
uh just
second yeah it's
yeah yes
and and great to get a quick
um view on
who's on the audience more than 10 years
of experience it's very interesting so i
look forward to some good interaction
and questions from all of you so as the
topic goes uh you know it's called how
career paths have changed
pursuing success through lifelong
learning it's big it's such a
um and it's a long topic but it's such a
very timely topic and and
after pandemic it's very
important it's it's on everybody's minds
but just to give you you know streamline
uh i was grateful to introduce me but
just to give a little more information
about myself and later you can look me
up on linkedin and we can stay connected
i'm a mechanical engineer by education
spend first six years of my career
working in sap erp implementations being
an i.t consultant doing programming
doing crm consulting
in between in first couple of years of
makita i was even an entrepreneur
tried to set up and run a learning
company which failed miserably but i
carried the lessons with me
and then i moved to hr and learning so
if i look at my own
uh experience and typically i
qualify as a millennial and at the cusp
of being a
you know gen x and a gen y or a
millionaire
so it's very interesting that i actually
had three different careers i'm not
talking about jobs three different
careers so when i kind of presenting
these slides and sharing some of these
opinions it's also coming from my own
personal experience so i have a total of
18 19 years of experience but actually
had three different careers and who
knows what the
future is is you know in store for all
of us right so kind of giving that
background and i think one thing which
helped me
to navigate through this
adventure this is my ability to learn or
my passion for learning so i thought i'd
give you a little background so there's
a lot to cover
so let's
jump right in so we all um are facing
the winds of change sometimes easy to
navigate sometimes really difficult
difficult at least last two years with
pandemic so many things have changed
so couple of things which are actually
changing the way we think act and work
globally it doesn't matter
which industry you work in doesn't
matter
whether you are from tech background
non-tech background doesn't matter
obviously the intensity of impact would
be different but the winds of change are
impacting everyone and the three big
wins of change coming our way is fourth
industrial revolution and there's so
much discussed about it since involved
world economic forum couple of years
back they coined the term and changed
industrial revolution is here primarily
driven through
something we call as emerging
technologies and these emerging
technologies there's no
those the usual suspects are let's say
ai ml blockchain iot vot
analytics
so on so forth agile and devops
but the whole bit about fourth
individual revolution is
it keeps changing contextually today
these are these technologies tomorrow
there could be something else and and
what's very interesting about fourth
industrial revolution is
the interlinkages of technologies how
iot
you know integrates with analytics or
iot analytics with ai or you know
blockchain it is how the interplay is
what's impacting the way we think act
and work and also blurring the
boundaries of industries so all the
body of knowledge we have about careers
in industries are is blurring like for
example
very common examples but let's say if i
take example of uber
in which industry would you qualify your
transport industry
or is it a platform industry or you know
now they're also into food delivery now
what industry does google fall into and
therefore if you're working for uber
what industry do you call it
and if you take example of a
um you know
a telecom giant in india airtel
and they also have a digital wallet they
also have you can even open a bank
account with them so that telecom are
they
e-commerce or they bank what are they so
it's very interesting that the bonus are
really blurry so there's that huge
change rate of change of technology
coming in human adaptability we are
first time ever in history i'll show
slide in next slide where humans have to
pull their socks literally and catch up
with the rate of change of technology
and therefore changing nature of that
the first wind of change affecting all
of us now the second wind of change
it is digital transformation especially
after pandemic so all the organizations
across various industries are in
various stages of digital transformation
and adoption
any company first is now a tech company
or a tech first company or need to think
tech first doesn't matter which industry
or what to service and after pandemic
companies have actually doubled down the
investment in digital transformation in
automation so and so forth i'll quickly
touch upon that so
there's need for at scale adoption of
automation and
its scale adoption of digital
transformation
uh interestingly the human adaptability
in the first side
moves into here and therefore there's a
huge skill gap for people for all of us
you know most of you on the caller over
10 years of experience i qualify into
the group so we need to play a catch-up
game and that's what we call re-skiing
or upscaling we'll discuss about that
the third wind of change is
pandemic you know unfortunately the way
it kind of affected the whole world and
we're still different parts of the world
are still grappling and coming out of
pandemic so
it had a huge impact on how we
look at work so when you look at uh
gen z or gen gen y
there's this famous word which is a term
which is controlled called y-o-l-o
yellow
it's called you only live once earlier
there was this famous term called
formula form of fear of missing out so
where all of us have glued onto our
mobile phones and we're kind of checking
every notification because we have this
fear of missing out but what pandemic
has done is
we all of us have re-looked at our lives
and made us my career job fall into the
overall scheme of things now people are
taking even in linkedin some people have
i was talking to somebody i saw the
linkedin profile in their profile it
says yo hello i believe in biola or
philosophy you only live on so if you
only live once
then what role does career play you know
there's a different pandemic has led to
all of those
uh
questions so so huge global experiments
in terms of hybrid workforce working
virtually working remotely therefore
changing work preferences because you
only live once and therefore for
organizations and also employees all
potential employees how do you look at
value proposition so these are the big
wins of change which are affecting
everything including as a narrow down
and zoom in little later about how
careers are perceived
by everyone in the industry
so little more details as i mentioned
earlier slide first i remember in the
history humans are trying to play the
ketchup girl if you see the exponential
curve adoption of technology is
exponential whereas human
you know uh adaptability is like a
almost uh not so steep slope so we're at
this interesting juncture where we need
to play the catch-up game and and that's
where the whole world is talking about
reskilling
upskilling that the two terms you would
hear
i'll also introduce another term called
metaskilling in a moment so very
interesting expert from book from thomas
friedman called thank you for being late
it's almost like we're already late to
the party and we need to ensure we play
the catch-up game
so um again a very short expert from a
hugely relevant report i highly
recommend all of you look it up it's the
world economic forum's future of jobs
report came out
october 2020 and it kind of projects
into the future how does future look
like in 2025
very detailed reporter of 200 pages free
are available on world economic forum's
website i highly recommend all of you
read it
one snapshot but very important one
you know uh based on the research across
industries across generations
across all genders you know what they
found was these are the top 15 skills
you know which are relevant for future
now if you spare a minute and you'll go
scan through this skills
something very interesting happens and
i'll explain it you look at
a skill number 7
technology use skill aid technology
design and programming and skill 12
troubleshooting
only
3 out of 15 skills are technology
focused
although we have 13 which is service
orientation which is more being customer
uh oriented which is always a mindset
right so if you
you know so 7 8
12
are kind of
um you know technology focus 13 is
mindset 14 system analysis and
evaluation is boring systems view
towards solving problems which is also
probably a mindset and also applying a
framework so except for these four
all other 11 skills are what we call
higher order cognitive thinking or
you know behavioral skills
look at
number one analytical thinking number
two active learning number three complex
problem solving critical thinking
creativity leadership social influence
resilience reasoning so what this means
is and i've actually written an article
which is published in
hr magazine i could share the link um
or it's available on my linkedin post so
so what this means is in the skills of
future perspective the way wins of
change are happening
all of us need to demonstrate higher
order skills of cognition of thinking
and how we manage our own emotions and
that's really critical because
the daily churn the churn activities
which can be uh automated through
business logic will be automated so the
only work left will be higher order kind
of work and which needs this higher
order skills that's a nice view to say
hey doesn't matter which industry i'm in
it i'm in consulting i'm in
manufacturing i mean you know
any other service industry hospitality
these are the skills needed in in most
of the roles it's very interesting to
look at that perspective start
reflecting
you know
how will your roles evolve because the
winds of change could evolve all of your
roles over the period of time some
industries will take
longer time some faster but our roles
are evolving and these are the skills
needed so we have
four years it's one year has already
gone past so you have four years to
build these skills and most of the
skills here i would coin them into the
category called meta skills
and you know that's like the theme of
the overall session anyway
lifelong learning right you know meta
skills are higher order skills which
when you acquire it has three qualities
one is their higher order skills second
they take a lot of time to acquire you
can't just go to a training session come
back and learn it it takes life
lifetime commitment or discipline to
learn so it's an ongoing journey and
third quality of a mental skill it's
very important is once you have a meta
skill it will help you pick other skills
faster let's take an example of skill
number
nine
in pandemic all of us went through
emotional turmoil and through the
emotional term all we had to take care
of our family our friends our career our
jobs and those of us who could
rebound faster respond faster by being
resilient being stress tolerant or able
to do a better job compared to others
therefore resilience becomes a meta
skill which will help you bounce back
during challenges likewise critical
thinking likewise uh number three
complex problem solving in a in a vuca
world in the post pandemic world we're
struggling with challenges which we
never faced so we don't have full
information so when you don't have full
information how do you how do you solve
problems which are ambiguous in nature
and if you have ability to do complex
problem solving then you have a meta
skill therefore you have an edge over
others so so i kind of use the term meta
skill i didn't make up this term it was
coined by mckinsey and ashoka university
so i need to give duke credit to them
but i really love the terms so metaskill
so most of these are meta skills
therefore it's good to see well document
forum giving your projection of future
five years so we have few years left to
kind of hone these skills and be ready
for future doesn't matter which industry
which role if you spend time on the
report
on world economic forum website
um
you will see
the projections for various industries
roles various industries also very
interesting so i'm sure depending on
your industry you'll find it useful so
that's one perspective then other
perspective is pandemic led to this huge
experiment i spoke about you only live
once
uh so what happened is now with the
future of work and this is a small
approach note which i've put together
talking to various people in the
industry saying that the future future
of work needs to be looked at threes
through length four lengths lengths of
work the work is changing digital
transformation fourth industrial
revolution it says the shifting
paradigms of industries and business
models the preferences of workers are
changing which we saw in the earlier
slide so you know uh future focused
employee centered you know eole levels
right approach on holistic therefore you
need to since my approach of careers are
changing so as organizations as
employees you need to
manage me differently so you need to
approach me holistically i'll talk about
that one of my last slides and also you
to engage me differently and the concept
of workplace has changed it's no longer
a physical place where you go
uh it's it's so therefore you say the
future workplace is more of a war than
why
what and why rather than aware right
because you know we have talked about
virtual we talked about remove it we're
talking about hybrid or a mix and
finally blurring out boundaries
ecosystem with gig economy
you know coming around the corner and
you know there's a lot of blurring of
boundaries has very various qualitations
one is great economy uh
organizations coming and integrating
together if they last
18 months huge m a in every industry
pharma
every industry you see a lot of merger
and acquisitions happening and also this
huge opportunity for academy and
industry to come and come together and
form forge uh partnerships for alternate
talent alternate skills so this is
another piece which is hugely
playing out on us so with that
background you know
veins of change
if i quickly sum it up for you so the
winds have changed at fourth industrial
revolution digital transformation and
pandemic experiments we spoke about how
technology is making shifts
first time ever in the history humans
are pushed to the corner
to kind of re-skill themselves to catch
up with technology
this is what needed for future meta
skills are the future irrespective of
the role skill industry and out of you
know 15 10 to 11 are real meta skills
and it takes a long time to build
and then
the future of work is shifting work work
about this ecosystem so that's like the
big picture of the means of change now
with this perspective with this
perspective
with this perspective let's deep dive
into
in this context
how does an ideal career look like
it's very interesting right you know how
do you define career
uh in this overall context so again the
three things i would return
i think the headline if you the biggest
headline if you have to take away from
this session is
uh you know career is all about
skills
it's all about skills
and that's the future and i'll talk more
about what it means that you know if you
want to focus on your career start
focusing on the skills you have the
skills right now the skills you need for
future you saw that next slide and also
what are some adjacent skills you have
because
uh industries are
merging their boundaries boundaries are
blurring so so
you might not just look at your primary
and secondary skills but what are some
adjacent skills where you can move into
i'll talk about that when you talk about
carried lattices also what are some you
know skills you can carry forward from
one job to another that becomes really
critical so
headline it's all about skills
so the first key takeaway be the ceo of
your career nobody else doesn't matter
you work for yourself you work for
anyone you are the ceo of your own
career so me inc you're the ceo for your
me inc i'm the ceo of my own career
therefore
plan career in increments you know what
would earlier what's your ten year
vision fire vision you know even in
interviews for you to be here really
with interview is to ask people now i
don't ask those questions because i'm
not sure what i'll do in 10 or 5 years
so you know increments of maybe 12
months 18 months
and a view to 2 to three years is enough
the way things are happening and as
things evolve so plan your career in
increments and increments not just
in time but mostly increments and skills
and not titles salary money that's also
important but that's not the only thing
saying hey it will
you know i'm director of learning and
development into entertainment to be a
vp
or you know a chief learning officer is
good but
what skills or experiences will make me
a good vice president
what skills or experience would make me
a successful chief learning officer it
are the increments i need to plan for
myself therefore i'll end up with a
title designation role or whatever right
so think in increments but think in
increments of skills first everything
else would follow
then you know
then you need to
drill down and ask what is my skill
inventory you know if i had to look at
my entire career profile how can i break
down my skills into inventory and see
how good i am in each one of this you
know that's very important we really
kind of do that it's very important to
start doing skill in every organization
creates a skill profile in inventory for
the employees but do you do it for
yourself is the question and therefore
once you have a skill inventory you ask
the question which of the skills i need
to build
a breadth of experience in which are the
skills and to build a depth of
experience i'll talk about that in the
next slide
and
therefore as i mentioned before if i
have to plan my career in increments the
most important question to ask is
what experiences will enable me to have
those increments of working what career
experiences what skill experiences will
help me get there
what challenges do i need to go through
to hone the skills because most of us
learn learn by doing yeah obviously we
do go to a classroom learn something
online but 70 percent at least the model
7210 the numbers are not perfect but at
least it's directionally correct most of
us learn by doing so put yourself in
situations where you face challenges
where you can try those skills different
so what challenges can you take up to
hone your skills to get to the
incremental progress and finally most
important who can support you
a mentor a coach a peer a buddy a go-to
resource that's very important right
so uh
let me see i try to pull up a website
i'll see that's still loading
maybe i'll come back later i wanted to
since i'm a hr learning development
professional i thought i'll show
skill inventory which is relevant for me
and my role and keep going back to this
model called american society of
training and development i have this
model called
uh atd capability development model
the website is loading maybe steve i can
ask you to try loading this up if you
just google it up atd capability model
or
atd talent development capability model
maybe if it loads faster for you later
we can see i wanted to show how i kind
of planned my my own career over the
last one decade comparing to the skill
inventory i'll come back to that
a little later
so now uh moving forward again
uh one
you know if the big headline was
the future is all about
skills
now this is how i want you to when i
mentioned plan your career in increments
plan your
career in increments of skills now i'm
breaking it down for you and
giving this approach
called
full stack professional we all know the
technical term beer no i'm a java full
stack developer or i'm a doctorate full
strength development or a full stack
analyst or never use the term full stack
from technology skills so i'm kind of
borrowing the term
uh from
jigsaw academy
and and the
proposal is this
we if we want to create careers for
ourselves for the future we have to
become full stack professionals and use
the word professional as a placeholder
so some of you might say i want to
become a full stack engineer some of you
might say i want to become a full stack
um
solution architect or i'm a full stack
manager or a full stack sales person or
a full stack leader or a full stack
um
any role right so replace the
professional whatever is your aspiration
you industry work with but the concept
stays the same the concept most
importantly is you know when you call it
full stack look at it from a holistic
360 approach the 360 approach is what
technical or functional skills you need
now and future
and that's not enough what business and
financial acumen you need
to be successful in that industry
to be successful to understand how
businesses work that's very important
that's the second aspect of full stack
the third is to enable your role what
behavioral leadership competencies would
i need including what meta skills do i
need which you saw in the idea slide
right problem solving so and so forth
and that's not enough
whatever role we play
technology you know every company is a
technology first company or needs to be
a technology first company every company
if we have to succeed have to be mobile
first in their solution from a
technology adoption and also think data
first so not just don't just think of
your role as technical and functional
skills of the role
domain skills
uh behavioral leadership skills but also
what
data literacy i need to be successful in
my role how do i act like a citizen data
analyst or a citizen data scientist
inside my organization
whatever is the scope of your role right
because data is all pervasive and sets
in so many conflicts of the organization
and being data literate and making
insights and decisions visualizing data
and drawing insights and being that
citizen data scientists and data citizen
data analysis terms we use a lot
think of your
you know
whatever role you are in whatever role
you want to be in this is the full stack
approach
and under each if you sit down and
reflect you can list down skills what
are the three to five technical skills i
need three to five function skills i
need three to five business domain
skills i need three to five financial
account skills three to five
behavioral leadership or meta skills and
two to three data
or mobile first skills that becomes your
skill inventory so you take this as a
frame a framework create your skill
inventory then against each skill just
rate yourself on its three scales
is my proficiency level zero
which means i'm a beginner is my
proficiency level 1 means i'm
intermediate or
and then is my proficiency level 2 which
is i'm advanced so proficiency how
proficient i am low medium high simple
so take all these areas listen at least
three skills under each on excel sheet
or a piece of paper and rate yourself
low medium high low medium and load
medium time that becomes your skill
inventory now with that skill inventory
plan increments keeping in view the 2025
skills and also the skills needed for
your industry add that to if this is
your current skill inventory what is my
20 25 skill entry looking like and
against that what's my proficiency level
0 one two you know where you are today
as is you know where you want to be and
you know the gap and you have a clear
personalized roadmap planned for you so
i think the future
for professions is to be full stack
professionals in the broader sense of
the world and and mapping your skill
inventory digging into the top
skills of future which you saw in the
earlier slide is a great way to
take this forward
so now taking it one step forward so
once you build your skill inventory some
of those skills technical industry
behavioral or meta skills you need
breadth of experience some you need to
build depth of experience and this is a
very famous career model called the
t-shaped model simple alphabet t
now draw a big alphabet t and say what
are from the skill inventory which you
made in the earlier slide um identify
skills
which will give you breadth of
experience generally their technical
skills industry exposure behavioral and
meta skills as you can see through the
legend but as you grow in your career
and since most of you have over a decade
of experience
as you want to you know grow in your
career in increments for the increments
in your career you want to make what are
the depth of skills you need to build
and generally they tend to be industrial
functional skills behavioral leadership
and meta skills are critical so kind of
list those so you will see
you have skill inventory but you will
also see
are you spread too thin
or are you
you know you don't have too much of
depth
once you take your skeleton
extrapolate in this model you will know
if you have enough breadth of skills and
enough depth of skills or where you are
lacking and that will also give you a
nice in thought of how you can plan your
next 18 to
24 months of career planning so you can
look up a lot of articles on t-shaped
career model but this i think the last
slide in this side particular can gives
you a good idea of where you fall but
you need to sit down and do a reflection
activity i can't do it for you i keep
doing it for myself but you have to do
it by yourself but i think with these
two three slides and earlier slide you
have enough information
to kind of sit down and do this kind of
homework for yourself so i highly
recommend you map your own skill
inventory rate your own proficiency
levels as is to be
and before you create as is to be look
at it through the lengths of breadth and
depth and see
for the future role in making increments
of it in 18 months or 24 months how much
of breadth and depth do you need and
this legends will let you know if
there's a technical skill industry
function skill behavioral leadership
meta skill or even
data skill data analytic skill so that
kind of helps you build a
career increment plan for yourself which
is all made up of skills
and the third piece i spoke about in the
when i said career is all about skills
experiences
and again a very evolved model earlier
when we spoke about
career growth the term growth career
professionally people
always thought it's a vertical
progression promotions growing up
growing up so but how how far will you
grow you know they need to be role
available in your location blah blah
blah there's so many restrictions right
and sometimes these are just in most
cases sometimes
your title changes but you're still
doing the same work maybe you will get a
little paid a little more right so it's
very important as i mentioned earlier
look for experiences which will help you
build that increments therefore
introducing the concept of career
lattice so like lattice is like a
intermission of things you see on the
center
so to get the skills you need from the
skill adventure you plotted for the tea
right then depth you need to ask
yourself in my organization in my
current role
can i do a project
laterally and then get a skill by doing
a diagonal role or doing a project or
can you do a move up then move down or
move you know sidewise you know be very
comfortable to kind of move across the
lightest there's no right vertical
progression but it's a lattice you need
to navigate yourself
and the fourth thing five things to keep
in mind
sometimes in the career lattice you move
vertically you look for opportunities
which will give you vertical growth
generally more seniority
more accountability more responsibility
so and so forth
sometimes it's a lateral movement inside
the organization
in a different role or a different
function sometimes it's natural movement
across in the industry you leave the
organization join somewhere
sometimes a job enrichment so you keep
adding to your role you add to your
existing role and sometimes it's
realignment you kind of take a step back
and say i looked at the top
uh 15 skills of the future and let me go
and invest and
invest in myself through the
organization or personally and build a
skill of aiml or build a skill of
lifelong learning so on so forth
sometimes it's also realignment which we
need to do some people go back to
business school some people do learning
as they go which is
you know more needed now because i don't
know how ready business schools are with
so much changing in the world this is
not a good time to in my opinion i could
be wrong to go back to business schools
you know you could learn a lot by just
talking to people and identifying what
are those skills and there's so many
learning opportunities we have that you
can learn while you work
so
again operating keyword is experiences
and if you see the title it says your
personalized choice of experiences so
based on the skill entry and the
and the journey you want to make in your
career
plan your personalized choices of
experiences and be comfortable
vertically laterally inside outside
enrichment
also realignment to give my own example
a couple of years back
i was in a mid management role senior
manager leading a team of 20 trainers
inside the organization managing the
entire portfolio of
managerial development for around 20 000
managers in a huge
one of the top five id organizations in
the country
after i spent a couple of years in the
role i took on
a talent management role
in a global mnc this role was indian
global mnc where i joined as a manager
talent management so more from senior
manager to managers so you've seen that
that is
coming down a little
um and i took an individual contributor
role so i kind of left my people
management aspect and there i built my
breadth of experience from learning to
talent management did that for four
years got global exposure learned talent
management
and then
after that again moved to become a
senior manager there and then after that
moved mayhem the career choice then i
realized i've learned enough talent
management
in the breadth and built my learning
and that learning depth
now i need to manage a team again
because i was losing all the skills of
managing teams so that's when i made
another shift to become a director of
learning a different organization so as
you move through career it's not just
about titles it's not just about
designation it's about the experiences
you need and that's how you need to plan
your career at career lattice really
helps to keep this fourth exempt
vertical lateral enrichment and
realignment
so
so again if i quickly summarize the
second section
what's an ideal career there's no ideal
career you need to personalize it for
yourself and it's all about skills so we
said be the ceo of your own career
uh skills of future start by building
your own scale inventory
start with the future
the full stack framework
and t model integrating those two look
at your scaling entry current and future
look at where you need to build depth of
experience where you need to build
breadth and consider what experiences
you need and follow the career let
yourself show the full stack here
technical functional business behavioral
leadership data
would be other things relevant for your
industry could be certain certifications
could be some other domain knowledge
could be regional knowledge sometimes
could be cultural knowledge language
skills could be some additional add-ons
that that makes it a full stack approach
and then
do your skill inventory and then review
it from breadth and depth and consider
where you need to have more breadth more
spread in increments not more than 18 to
24 months don't think beyond that as of
now maybe later you're spectacular
then
think of experiences you need and plant
vertical lateral enrichment real
admitting complicated as a lattice not
just as a lateral progression
now to enable all this we need to become
a lifelong learner and couple of inputs
i'd like to add is meta skills as i
mentioned before
uh you saw in the top 15 skills of the
future it's important to build meta
skills and three meta skills i think are
really critical to practice every day
starting today's growth mindset i'll
talk about that in next slide and
agility agility kind of comes from truth
mindset but also ability to kind of move
faster
uh adapt as things go
and emotional intelligence and
resilience which we saw as a huge need
especially the post panamic world
and to build growth mindset once we talk
about growth management generally plus
yes it's a great concept now how do i
build growth mindset the answer is by
being curious i'll talk about three
sides of being curious and there's an
assessment all of you can take and
finally
when things are ambiguous you always
have to start with yourself you don't
remember me or the ceo of your own
organization so you need to ask three
simple questions very powerful questions
what are my values
what are my strengths
and what's my purpose and legacy i know
the word purpose and legacy sound very
heavy
but it's worth asking yourself
what's your purpose personally
professionally and what legacy you want
to leave behind because you know what
you only live once we live in a yolo
world right so so from a meta skills
perspective addressing growth mindset is
really critical so that two types of
mindset fixed mindset and growth mindset
this concept got introduced by carol
dweck in the book mindset i highly
recommend you read this book you look up
ted talks that quite a few ted talks
done by her you know she worked with
school children
who were failing in their school and she
just tweaked
uh you know the mindset of the kids to
say
who started telling themselves i'm not
good in mathematics i'm not good in
english i'm not input in science so she
started doing this simple experiment so
when you give the scorecard to the kids
in school uh you know you give grades
right abcdef or whatever happens in each
country
she started replacing the grades of
people kids who got low scores
instead of saying failed or create f she
started using the term not yet
and that's the growth mindset if you
have to summarize it's the power of not
yet
you're not there yet
but you're on the journey which means
you're going to embrace challenges and
raise obstacles
put in effort effort cannot talent
cannot replace effort
effort can multiply talent but talent
cannot replace just because your skill
doesn't mean you can't put effort
especially effort can multiply talent
and embrace failure
failure is not the end of things failure
is a stepping stone and that's and then
embrace criticism and finally
in you know um
find inspiration that their successes
don't feel threatened so if you look at
kind of
start doing those and take the not yet
mindset then you will realize the
abilities you have are not static they
can be built and developed for example
if you go back to neuroscience you know
we have over three billion connect uh
synapse connections which form in our
brain
pretty young by three to seven four to
five to seven years you know three
billion connections form
but with practice
even as you grow older as you become
adults you can create new synapse
connections in your mind which means
your worldview your perceptions the way
you look at things the way you solve
problems the way you deal with your
emotions can be changed but it takes
effort takes discipline and that's why
think on the right hand side abilities
can be developed challenge should be
embraced persist in phase of obstacles
um value effort do not
efforts multiply talent talent cannot
replace effort and seek opportunities
for growth and failure and embrace
criticism and and find inspiration from
other success that's when you are on
journey of growth mindset which is
really important because if you have to
build skills of lifelong learning which
we saw all those 15 skills
you need to have you know skills of
you to have this ability to embrace
group mindset now uh to do this the
first step to embrace growth mindset is
to be build curiosity
you know especially in a world which is
changing so much with so much of means
of change it's really important to stay
curious so curiosity can be broken down
to three things how curious am i about
myself my emotional intelligence
self-awareness
reflection is very important
journaling take time every week to
reflect what went well what did not go
well what can you do differently or
three simple times three simple words
start stop continue what can i start
doing differently what can i stop doing
from today and what should i continue
doing you know
so curiosity about yourself curiosity
about people and curiosity about the
world and there's a simple free
assessment if you google it's go to
global curiosity institute you can take
the free assessment you'll get your own
report i took my own report last year
and working on my own curiosity quotient
it gives you advice also
what areas you have to build on for
example i got pretty decent scores on a
scale of 100 over 17 all the three but
my least score is curiosity about others
and i'm kind of working on it to get
more curious with people
so uh
and that the last and most important
piece you know
in a post-pandemic world where you only
live once
you know it's important to bring your
whole self to your career
you know it's important to bring your
own you can't live part of your part of
you at home because most of us are
working from home right so so you have
to bring your whole self to career so
when think of your career goals career
aspirations
start putting when you think of your
purpose when you think of your legacy
think of your goals you want for 18
months 24 months
ensure these four aspects of your whole
person which is about you
are addressed ensure you're getting the
right intellectual alignment in the job
role you want to do in the career you
want to have which means your talent and
strength should be used your skills
should be developed and you should be
engaged creatively ensure you have
psychological safety which means you
feel grounded you feel anchored you feel
safe you feel you are treated
fair uh you know with fairness and your
health and well-being
is taken care of and ensure you have an
emotional alignment right so that you're
surrendering with people who treat you
with empathy
people who engage you to understand your
motivation motivations and aspirations
people who invoke loyalty in you trust
in you and finally where you feel you
can grow outside your role and start
volunteering for causes which are
important and finally find alignment
with your spirit which is your purpose
and alignment are my personal values
aligned to values of this organization
our mind is my personal vision enriched
by working for the vision of this
organization and finally the million
dollar question
what's what's the legacy i want to leave
behind and can this work with this
career in this role help me build my
legacy which is adding meaning and
contributions so don't just think of
career as something outside you start
with your own values your own strengths
your personal vision so
the whole world is moving to this the
whole organizations
now to engage people need to treat
employees as whole persons look it
through the lens of whole person
paradigm so now organizations are
thinking how to engage
minds of employees engage
you know psychological safety heart and
spirit
let them do their job
but when you plan for your own career
look at it from full person plus whole
person perspective so that you find
fulfillment in your own goals purpose
values right so that's my last comment i
want to make sure to quickly summarize
the third section about being lifelong
learner
you know uh build meta skills start by
growth mindset we spoke a lot about the
power of not yet then start with
curiosity go and take your curiosity
assessment from global curiosity
institute you'll get report across these
three sections based on your scores have
a plan and work towards improving as i'm
doing it myself and finally when you
think of your career goals the purpose
and legacy bring your own person to it
so therefore
any career any job
you have a vision for yourself 18 24
months from now
you know it needs to have have
intellectual alignment with your mind
psychological safety for your body to
accurate emotional alignment to your
heart and
purpose and alignment to bring your
spirit alive in everything
so
that's what i wanted to cover
um you know those are the coordinates
which you can reach me you can scan the
qr code connect to me through linkedin
or drop in a note to me but turn it out
to steam now and if you have a few
minutes we can take some q a
all right thank you um so
i know that was a fantastic presentation
and i'm
getting a lot of great comments and
questions
and i'd like to um
before we do that i'm going to share my
screen again so if you'll bear with me
and we'll ask the audience a poll
question
sure
okay
so this
two-part question
get the
pull
get the pole going hold on a second
and there we go
again if you're watching on streaming
you can put
answers in the comments
but uh you should if you're watching
through
webex you should have the widget up
and we're asking what
skills are you most interested in
learning
outside of the meta skills these are
more particular technology and
management skills but um
as as arnold pointed out the meta skills
that he discussed
are
equally it's a lifetime it takes a
lifetime so you they're not stopping
here
and
you can see that uh
today's audience is very interested in
project management type skills
as well as data science and ai
but across the board they're
folks
yeah uh interested in various aspects
and
it's good to see that more than a third
of you
are interested in doing that right away
so
and
so if
this kind of aligns really well with the
research from world economic forum where
the top three technologies adopted at
scale
are
cloud
analytics and aiml so clearly it's
aligned to what's happening across the
industry too yeah
all right so um
rather than make everybody stare at that
stop sharing for a moment
let everybody stare at my face instead
and we'll talk about
questions that came up we have
various questions that came from
our linkedin audience as well
so uh
how do we keep up with
rapid change
technology evolves too fast and how do
you choose the right skills mary grayson
yeah
no i think that's a great question so i
mean there's no choice i mean you saw
the competition between
technology and humans right we need to
keep up with the rapid change what i
would recommend highly recommend is
start
building the skill of learning
learning agility so
uh um
steve i'm sorry i'm going to give name
of another digital platform but you know
apologies so this is famous
course called learning how to learn it's
also a book
and if you look up it's in one of the
famous digital platforms it's a free
move course i highly recommend for
everyone go and do that course called
it's actually most signed up course in
this platform learning how to learn i
think the more we learn how to learn
then we'll cope to learn faster with new
technologies and gives i actually i i
read the book learning how to learn with
my nine-year-old the book is written for
kids too so it's i would recommend
there's no other choice we need to learn
how to learn faster build learning
agility so i would highly recommend
building that meta skill straight away
okay
um and
the giannion uh asks a interesting
question
what would your suggestion be for
somebody who has
extensive 15 years of i.t experience in
data warehouse
is
would you advise
them how would you advise them to
grow their career
or pursue their career
yeah i think
you know if
in the
career lattice slide there was a last
option called realignment right if you
want to realign you could look at
broader industry for example you know
the whole industry of analytics
again from an i.t you can combine
analytics as eimel and analytics
together but just look at the area of
analytics as
entire progression of
careers and and if i just split it into
four
in a broader role category so from data
analyst to data wrangler from data
wrangler to data operations to data
scientists is a huge career path and if
you have over 10 15 years experience in
data warehouse you should look at a
potential
role or career realignment into becoming
a data scientist if that interview so
please look it up and i'm sure
somebody like
[Music]
you know simply learn has quite a few
learning around it
so yeah you can look it up from the
roadmap perspective
um
related question
first from panoshi uh who asks
what factors should one consider in
order
to plan out realignment
what are the the what are the things
that you should
look at in yourself in your career and
then in planning i think that's a
brilliant question and it's the answer
is highly personalized but i think let's
take an outside in view first
think of uh you know if you do a little
bit of google search
uh the new roles of future and which
roles are getting declined you go back
to world economic forum report i
mentioned you'll see that a lot of roles
which are getting declined in next
couple of years so look at your current
role and see what are the chances that
your role how much percent of your role
can be automated and if it's more than
40 percent then i think you should start
thinking of realignment because if
computers can do what you're doing then
your job is obviously at risk and um
there's this uh forgetting name of the
author so there's this guy who was head
of google in china he left that now he
runs his own vc and he recently
published a book of evolution of ai and
he did some couple of podcasts if you
look him up he his prediction and it's
his prediction it's not industry what
his prediction is in next three to four
years a lot of uh when we talk about uh
roles getting automated many of us think
the blue-collar roles you know roles in
factories or you know people are doing
lower rung of the ladder kind of roles
will get automated but his prediction is
first it will start the first wave will
hit with the white collar jobs because
most of the
roles we are doing in white collar jobs
more than if 40 more than 40 percent of
your role can be automated then your
role is at risk so i'll definitely look
at a realignment right there so so do a
little bit of research start with the
atomic forum and then
that's the outside approach now inside
approach inside out approaches you need
to
invest in this learning which is
important you to build a discipline of
lifelong learner and build growth
mindset which is which some of us learn
faster some take time but there's no
choice the sooner we start
okay
mara has a question regarding the
t-shaped profile which is
the question is is versatility and not
versatility and knowledge in many
domains a good or bad skill to have
so versatility is nothing but breadth in
my opinion right because that gives
breadth now knowledge is a tricky one
you know
wikipedia has knowledge you know uh you
know a college-going kid can
pull out more
write a nice white so you know gone are
the days you know when i was when i was
a kid i used to walk into my
uh uncle's home and see this huge hard
bound
britannica
encyclopedias and used to get amazed
about the whole knowledge of the world
is stored in a room and which only few
people could buy but now knowledge is
for free so is knowledge a
differentiator i don't think so
versatility is because everybody can
pick knowledge what's important is
applied skills can you actually apply
the skills and how faster can you
learn and apply is it differentiated
versatility always helps now having a
breath always helps but you to balance
that with depth also yeah knowledge is
good to uh to learn where the industry
is going it helps you be more curious
but you need to build more than that
many decades ago when i was a an
engineering student
i remember taking an electrical
engineering final and the professor said
you can bring in a three by five three
inch by five inch
card and you can write whatever you want
on both sides as much as you like
if you think that will help you pass
this final and the way to do it was
you write in
the forms of formulas
you don't write in answers to questions
because the problem the
way to
pass the final is to recognize
what a particular question was asking
and
where which answer not the specific data
that they were asking for
but what formula applied to that so
that was a valuable lesson of knowing
how to look at the problem rather than
how to look for the solution so
um
we have a question about
the last question i'll take that last
comment posted twice about
parenting having affecting the career
oh okay yeah i think
what i would like to say is now many
organizations are very open to career
breaks now earlier they were like you
know kind of cynical to say hey why do
you have a career break so and so forth
but now if you look at
uh gen wise they actually take pride in
taking career break and traveling across
the world i know many of my friends and
colleagues who have been doing that and
people take breaks for
you know being caretakers taking care of
their family members or could be
parenting could be kids could be higher
education now it's a fairly norm it's a
fairly normal
thing so don't worry about it take pride
in the reason why you had to
you know move away from career and take
care of things talk about it
and and the industry is vibrantly open
now there's so many open openings now
out there so people are looking for
alternate talent so don't worry about
that at all take pride in the reason you
took a break and talk about it you don't
have to hide anything and i think
industry is also embracing that from a
diversity and inclusion perspective also
you know time i'd like to ask
a couple people ask about the future of
sales and marketing
and that domain is do you see that as
a growth domain
definitely so if you uh you know when i
did the earlier session i did have some
slides on that from world economic forum
uh so
uh see marketing obviously will have a
huge from digital transformation will be
more digital marketing focused
so you know if you look at a
company like google you know they have
this
website called
rework rewrq rework
all the best practices they have in
google they publish for free in fact i
subscribe to a couple of marketing uh
courses from google which that you want
for free if you are interested you
should look them up uh sales very
interestingly if you go back to world
economic forums report what it says is
sales is one of those industries in next
couple of years they'll be open to
taking people from other industries
sales is one of those industries which
will be extremely open to invite people
from others so so there you go which
means
uh the roles are opening up or there is
a gap in the in the field right it's a
combination of both so they're both open
to embracing skills means that
transferable skills involved and also
there's a lot of things happening so
i'll go back to world atomic forum
there's a section on sales you should
read up but i think based on what i've
seen it's uh you know that's what i can
change yeah
okay
um we have a question from the youtube
audience about
uh is there a centralized resource or a
a single place that you would
ask somebody to start
um
when they're starting out on their
journey of self-improvement
oh that's a tough question i think
there's so many learning resources so
many moves
um start with the curiosity assessment i
told you there's another website called
uh value inaction values in action
v i a character dot org
if you go there you can take a
free self assessment on your personal
values so i would say start with values
in action character.org and then global
curiosity institute take those two free
assessment but nothing can replace
reflection i would highly recommend
time for self-reflection and the best
way to self-reflect is
uh
journaling your thoughts putting it on a
piece of paper i know we all transition
to digital journaling and there's an
interesting research which says when you
make nodes on a digital equipment
compared to making notes on a piece of
paper when you make notes on a piece of
paper
different parts of your brain get
activated which don't get activated when
you use a mobile phone
so
do old school go to sit down attack have
some reflection time and do journaling
once a week simple three questions
start stop continue based on what
happened this week what should i start
doing what should i stop doing what
should i continue it doesn't hurt to
have a mentor or a coach so feel free to
reach out to people unless you reach out
to them and ask for support nobody is
going to help out so feel free
great avenues like linkedin you can just
reach out to people and you will be
happy to see how many people are willing
to support you
i think the last question because we did
have a question um
from a phd uh in computer science who's
been working as an assistant professor
i think his question is about
realignment and i think
addressed that so i want to ask a
different question from
someone maybe
from people from academia is there's a
huge need to
uh have stronger partnership with
corporations and the other way around
too i think there's a huge gap in
academia and corporate so do your bet if
you want to continue in academia
try to build partnerships now
organizations are more willing to build
partnerships you know the skills of
future
doing pocs povs i personally
uh
partnered with uh mba school in india
and then we recently did a huge study on
diversity inclusion and i'm working with
them to publish couple of case studies
so you'll learn a lot of things in those
partnerships and and
one mba graduate
actually taught me analytics in the
process i learned a lot in the whole
process i'm extremely proud of it
and that that's a that's very good
advice for this particular
individual because
they've moved between industry and
academia so it's encouraging that
you're talking about
the fluidity of being able to move back
and forth
and combine the two the last question i
wanted to take from a youtube user is
someone who is
studying
both networking and software engineering
um on their own and
the question is is it better to focus on
one or the other or continue to do both
i think
both for now because the way
entire cloud and infrastructure space is
evolving it doesn't hurt to be a
networking guy with some coding you know
and then now cloud is evolving to devops
and devops evolving there's so many new
roles coming up in cloud 2 where
knowing how to code would
would have been if you want to make the
career other way around in development
and have cloud anyway now all native
apps are all
offline apps and now cloud native apps
so it's going to help you that way too
so so you're starting with networking i
would say picked a few more skills in
cloud you know you could pick uh
an aws azure or google you know any of
the csps but that wouldn't hurt so
that's what i would say
excellent
so i we've kept you a little bit over
time and i wanted to thank you very very
much i know for
as i said an excellent presentation very
engaged uh audience
um and
uh the people who've asked for the
presentation we will be sending out a
link
to a recording of this uh
event yeah i'll send the pdf slides also
to you if it helps you do it up there
and is there a way to i know there are
quite a few ques uh questions in chat
and q and a if there's a way to
uh
download them and send maybe i'll even
try to
respond to some of them and i i will i
will do that yes we do have a
record of that from webex i guess
um so thank you very much for that and i
i i'm showing on the screen
your linkedin i've also dropped that
into the chat previously so
um
people can
connect with you and of course you put
up your
qr code
um
and i wanted to thank everybody for
being in our audience today
um
we do encourage you to connect with us
uh on our social media channels at
simplylearn
simplylearn on linkedin
and we will be having
more
webinars in this series
we have career webinars we have
technical
webinars
um on specific domains
we have um
other
webinars coming up on
a
career strategy and we'll be
inviting you to those so keep an eye out
for that we hope to
have you join us and we hope to see you
as part of our simply learn learning
family in the future
thank you all very very much and thanks
again to anya
thank you it's been a pleasure i always
enjoy these interactions so
thank you thanks everyone have a good
day
foreign